most people in the car industry have
been talking about autonomous driving
for the past six years
car makers were dropping the terms
mobility and self-driving in car shows
while uber and others poached university
engineers from robotics laboratories on
moss and tesla fans argued on twitter
the firm's autopilot system could be
termed autonomous at the same time
urban planners were rethinking town's
designs to plan and envision an
automotive detritus absence of traffic
stop lights and cars parked at one
roadside cars would just drop you at
your place and
boom vanish practically many people were
so hopeful about the self-driving
feature that the then secretary of
transportation in the us
anthony fox proclaimed that fully
autonomous cars would be everywhere
by 2021 however fast forward to today
the buzz is no longer there you'll hear
less about self-driving cars than a few
years ago the prospect of fully
autonomous cars is becoming a distant
fantasy why the radio silence
watch on as i explain the reasons why
tesla self-driving cars
are not yet a reality welcome back to
our channel if you haven't already
make sure you hit the subscribe button
and ring that bell so you're notified
every time we upload a new video
understanding self-driving car it can
mean a fully autonomous car that doesn't
want a human driver behind the wheel
though it's not fully operational as
envisioned
several semi-autonomous features are
available in the cars on the road
already the autonomous tools utilize
various sensors to know what happens on
the road
and use sophisticated computing powers
to decide for the car
the change to fully autonomous cars
doesn't happen at once
it happens gradually as features that
need drivers to do less work roll out
since 2020 all new teslas have been
featured with a full self-driving
computer but car owners must buy the 10
dollar full self-driving capability
package to have the features
the tesla ceo said that owners would
have access to the technology
but the vehicles won't still be fully
self-driving reasons why tesla
self-driving cars
are not yet a reality elon musk believes
his firm tesla would have fully
autonomous vehicles everywhere by 2021.
he said in 2020 that there are
fundamental challenges remaining there
are many small problems and then there's
the challenges of solving all those
small problems and putting the whole
systems together
musk finally admitted that he
underestimated how hard it is to design
a reliable self-driving car
the engineering community had already
debunked the full self-driving success
earlier but what could be the reason for
this shortfall continue watching as i
unravel the reasons
developing sensors a fully self-driving
vehicle uses sensors to view its
environment and helping cars to detect
things like other cars
pedestrians or road signs the cameras
also help vehicles to view objects while
the lidar utilizes lasers to measure or
determine the space between vehicles and
objects
also radar tracks a car's direction and
speed and detects objects
these sensors feed data to the vehicle's
computer to aid it in deciding when to
brake or where to steer
specifically fully autonomous vehicles
require a broad set of sensors
that could detect objects accurately and
aptly capture the speed and distance
under any environment or conditions
devoid of human intervention some
conditions like huge traffic
lousy weather graffitied road signs can
adversely affect the sensing ability
accuracy tesla uses radar and it's less
susceptible to bad weather conditions
meanwhile there's still a challenge to
ensure that the selected sensors
utilized in fully autonomous vehicles
can detect every object with the needed
certainty for the vehicles to be secured
to achieve a fully autonomous vehicle
the sensor should work in every weather
condition globally
a series of tesla cars accidents since
shows that the firm has a long way to go
in producing global and
all-weather self-driving cars developing
sensors that would operate flawlessly in
every type of weather and visibility
condition
including teaching vehicles ways to
react to edge cases they would encounter
on the road
are still lacking they're the main
reason why tesla self-driving cars
aren't a reality yet machine learning
and artificial intelligence
similarly most autonomous vehicles would
utilize machine learning and artificial
intelligence to process data from their
sensors
to help decide their next actions the
algorithms would help to know the
objects detected by the sensors while
classifying them based on the training
of the system
as street lights and pedestrians the
vehicle will then utilize the
information to decide if it requires
taking action
like swerving or braking to prevent
detected objects later in the future
the machine can detect objects and
classify them more efficiently than the
human driver
there is currently no widely agreed and
accepted basis which ensures that the
machine learning algorithms utilized in
the vehicles are safe
in other words there's no general
agreement on how machine learning needs
to be tested
trained or validated on tesla cars
acceptability
a series of tesla cars accident since
2020 plus
accidents involving other autonomous and
automated cars has affected the
self-driving car's social acceptability
it's not the only problem with people
that want to purchase self-driving
vehicles but equally for other road
sharing users
the general public should be engaged in
some decisions on the adoption and
introduction of self-driving cars
without a clear-cut collaboration and
explanation on the car's safety
safety's evidence and operation with the
public and regulators to get some levels
of approval
these tesla fully self-driving vehicles
would remain a fantasy
in other words musk needs to solve the
issue of social acceptability first
through an effective collaboration on
challenges on safety regulation
assurance and acceptance accidents
involving tesla self-driving vehicles
tesla self-driving cars have been
involved in some accidents
including in florida and texas where the
videos went viral the accident
highlights confusion on tesla's
automotive driving abilities and the
ways people use them even though all new
tesla cars have cameras and sensors and
the firm claims it delivers autonomous
driving features the cars are still
without accidents
it has been observed that tesla
autonomous driving features aren't the
same and more
elaborate like self-driving cars from
firms such as waymo even with a fully
autonomous car
many self-driving vehicles would be
semi-automatic for now trying to know
who has the responsibility and when
could be tricky
it could be tricky for the car to notify
passenger times moreover what could
happen if human passengers go against
self-driving vehicles on the road
often humans might wish to control but
the cars aren't always programmed or
designed to oblige
vehicles don't pass through a vacuum
infrastructures and roads plus the state
local and federal regulations
need to welcome many robocars as stated
the public has to be involved
level 5 autonomy level 5 is the highest
level of autonomy for self-driving cars
this level entails that the car can do
all the driving in any circumstance
it is driving entirely autonomously
without need for human involvement or
intervention in any weather condition
night or day or road full self-driving
features are
auto lane change navigate on autopilot
summon the act of moving vehicles around
tight spaces with just a key or mobile
app
smart summon navigating in more complex
surroundings and in parking spaces
auto steer on town streets traffic and
stop sign control
however tesla's autopilot system
presently lies at partial automation
or level two the vehicle could
autonomously do some functions like
acceleration
steering and braking nevertheless tesla
needs every driver to keep control of
the car while on autopilot there can be
fatal consequences when you fail to do
so
for instance some fatal crashes have
happened involving tesla cars on
autopilot enabled in other words tesla
vehicles aren't still driving at their
discretion and they're far from catching
the highest level 5 of autonomy
in january 2021 during an earnings call
interview
musk stated that he was highly confident
the car will be able to drive itself
with reliability in excess of humans
this year be that as it may
tesla might not reach level 5 autonomy
by 2021 end
before i conclude this topic let me
bring your attention to tesla's latest
attempt at its car automation
tesla steps so far to have an autonomous
car autopilot presently needs drivers to
pay apt attention and always keep their
hands on steering wheels
however some drivers are relying too
much on the tech while some avoid tesla
safety features
now people are seen on videos riding in
the back seat while others sleep at the
wheel because of the engaged autopilot
thus there has been a rise in recorded
autopilot-related crashes
consequently tesla has attempted to
enhance autopilot's autonomous abilities
by including an automatic lane changing
feature
which is presently bringing the full
self-driving feature in beta mode for a
few groups of drivers
musk has promised to make tesla vehicles
fully autonomous and even plans on some
model releases later in the year
hey don't fret fully self-driving or
highly automated driving can still be
possible
one that's enabled by technology that's
racing forward and fast
computer processing abilities and
continuous learning of sophisticated
artificial intelligence systems are the
key
things toward this drive more so an
on-board sensor system needed to detect
cars
monitor behavior and read the
surroundings as growing possible as days
pass
moreover there are these vital
communication systems that would link
everything together
they are 5g cellular networks and cloud
computing the 5g
network will make the wireless speeds
faster than the 4g network in use
at the same time the cloud system
permits engineers to release much data
processing from the cars themselves into
more rigorous and capable updated
servers
the 5g network would be the game changer
as it will offer some key features
although the vehicles would operate with
no connectivity having a faster
robust and higher bandwidth data system
would profoundly boost the autonomous
car network's abilities
countries or cities can optimize their
traffic patterns vehicles would be aware
of the period traffic signals would be
at the intersections and cars can
communicate with each other to adjust
during bad weather or any issue
will tesla achieve full self-driving are
tesla self-driving cars safe we want to
hear your opinion on this
leave us a comment below in the meantime
if you enjoyed this video
give it a like and check out more
awesome ones on the simply tech channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time